according to figures in the new Census  Data the number of people living in  England and Wales born outside the  United Kingdom has now risen to 10  million the office for National  statistics says this is an increase of  two and a half million since 2011. that  means that around one in six people  living in England and Wales were born  abroad the biggest increase was in the  number of people born in Romania there  has been a 576 percent rise in  romanian-born residents from around 80  000 in 2011 to 539  000 in 2021 meanwhile people born in  India were the biggest group of  foreign-born Nationals 920  000 people making up 1.5 percent of the  population of England and Wales